I canceled my Claude code subscription
last month and not because Claude code
got worse. I canceled it because one
open source tool now lets me run Claude
code for almost nothing. The gateway is
called Omni route. It is a free router,
one endpoint on your machine, over 200
providers sitting behind it. 50 of those
providers ship a free tier. 11 of them
stay free forever. Wire it into Claude
code and you get the exact same
experience you already love. Model
agnostic routing, no 5-hour timer, and a
bill that trends towards zero. Let me be
fair up front. Claude code is one of the
best coding tools anyone has shipped.
Opus is still what I reach for on the
hardest problems. So, this is not a
takedown. This is about the subscription
cost and the usage ceiling and why the
thing I was paying to avoid finally has
a workaround. So, here is the entire
build, start to finish, plus the honest
places where it still has limits. Start
with the part people skip past. Claude
code itself is not the problem. The
problem is the meter underneath it. The
pro plan is $20 a month. Max runs $100
to $200. Your usage refills on a rolling
5-hour window with a weekly cap stacked
on top of it. Hit the ceiling in the
middle of a task and you either wait it
out or flip to pay as you go and watch
the tokens tick past your budget.
Anthropic even doubled those limits back
in May, which tells you how often people
were slamming into them. Add it all up
and here is your position. A tool you
genuinely love on a clock you do not
control. For occasional work, that is
completely fine. For someone in the
terminal all day, the ceiling shows up
sooner than you would like. What I
actually wanted was small. The exact
same tight loop of read, edit, run, and
fix. The same Claude code interface I
already had muscle memory for, but with
my own keys, my own routing, and no
5-hour timer tapping me on the shoulder
halfway through an afternoon of real
work. It turns out that precise wish is
what Omni route was built to grant. So,
let me walk through what Omni route
actually is and then show you how it
snaps into Claude code. Omni route is a
free gateway you run yourself. One open
AI compatible endpoint sitting on
localhost and behind it every provider
you own stitched into a single tidy list
of models Claude code can pick from. The
headline numbers are the whole pitch.
230 plus providers reachable through one
address. More than 50 of them carry a
free tier. 11 stay permanently free. No
credit card at all. Claude code only
ever sees that one localhost endpoint
and Omni route decides which provider
actually answers. The feature that earns
the name is fallback. If a provider goes
down, gets rate limited, or just drags,
Omni route reroutes the very same
request to a healthy one on its own mid
request without bothering you. Its
tagline is word for word never stop
coding and that turns out to be the
entire point of the thing. Then comes
the compression which is smarter than it
sounds. Coding agents fire off enormous
repetitive tool payloads on every turn.
Omni route runs two passes it calls RTK
and caveman and on that tool heavy
traffic it strips out 78 to 95% of the
tokens before they ever hit the model
and it is careful about exactly the part
that scares you. Your code, your URLs,
and your structured JSON come through
byte for byte identical. It only
squeezes the repetitive pros and the
tool chatter and it leaves the actual
source you are shipping completely
untouched. On privacy, it stays home.
Omni route runs entirely on your own
hardware. Your provider keys stay on the
box and it does not phone out to anyone.
You get all of the routing and none of
the usual price which is handing some
middleman a full copy of your traffic.
It is not a thin little proxy either. It
ships around 94 built-in tools over the
model context protocol plus a semantic
cache that remembers answers it has
already computed. So, a repeated
question can skip the model entirely and
come back instantly for free. Underneath
all of it are 18 routing strategies to
pick from. Cheapest first, fastest
first, weighted splits, hard cost caps,
and a few more. You set the policy one
time, then forget it, while the gateway
makes the actual call on every single
request. Now, watch the two click into
one thing. Omni route has a button that
generates a Claude code config for you.
It spits out a ready file with every
model it can reach already listed
inside. You drop that file in place,
point Claude code at the localhost
endpoint, and the agent is wired to the
whole pool. With that, the loop closes.
You type a task into Claude code. It
plans the change, edits your files, runs
the tests, reads whatever the compiler
complained about, and fixes it. Then
loops again until things pass. It is the
exact same agentic rhythm you already
know. The whole difference lies
underneath. The tokens are now flowing
through 50 free tiers with automatic
fallbacks standing in front of them.
That free pool alone documents around 1
and 1/2 billion tokens a month, which is
far more headroom than a single
developer can burn. So, the money math
simply flips. The workflow that used to
mean a subscription plus overage now
leans on free capacity first and only
reaches for a paid Anthropic key when
you genuinely want Opus on one hard
problem. Most afternoons, honestly, I
never reach for it at all. And that
5-hour window, for me, it is simply
gone. When one provider taps out, the
next one picks the session up without a
single pause. I work straight through
the day, and nothing pops up to tell me
to come back in a few hours once the
meter cools off. Here's where the
compression really pays off. On a long,
tool-heavy session, cutting 78% to 95%
of the tokens means the same work that
used to burn clean through a paid budget
now barely dents a free one. The savings
and the fallback compound on each other.
That was the afternoon I canceled the
subscription. The same Claude code
interface, my own routing, and no meter
running in the corner of the screen.
Now, the honest half, because none of
this is magic. Free tiers come with real
strings attached. Slower models, tighter
rate limits, and quality that swings
depending on which provider you happen
to land on. Fallback softens all of
that. It does not make it disappear. You
are also the integrator now. The default
Claude code setup simply works the
second it installs. No wiring at all.
This setup adds a config file and a
handful of provider keys you have to
manage yourself. More control, but
genuinely more assembly required on your
end. And on the truly hard problems,
Opus still pulls clearly ahead of the
free pack. If a single task is worth the
best brain that money can rent, just
point Claude code at your paid Anthropic
key for that task. That is simply not
what most of my day actually looks like.
So, the verdict is not that Claude code
lost. Keep your paid key for the heavy,
model-sensitive work where Opus
genuinely shines. Let Omni route carry
everything else, which, if your day
looks anything like mine, ends up being
most of it. The real shift under all of
it is that the interface and the billing
finally came apart. The loop you love is
still the loop. The brain is now a
choice you make per task, and the bill
turned into something optional. Once you
have felt what that is like, it is
genuinely hard to go back. Same Claude
code, any model, almost no bill. That is
why I canceled my subscription.